hey guys it's Jonah here so today's
workout is going to be an advanced
strength training which you can do from
the comfort of your own home so if you
want to push yourself if you want to
progress to the next level then do this
workout it's going to be a combination
of upper body and also lower body
strength training exercises we want to
import about ten repetitions for each
workout there will be a total of six
exercises and remember to get your body
warmed up okay so give me a best-effort
and let's do this
this is going to be a circuit strength
training and because it's only ten
repetitions
I wanted you to lift heavier the first
workout is going to be a squat with
single arm show the press alright we
want to alternate between left and right
so I'm going to go for six kilos of
dumbbell let's go so squat stand
shoulder-width apart
flip it bend your knees push it up okay
let's go again - and push it up good so
you're using the strength from your
lower body and we saw that strength from
your shoulders
flip it and up good keep going and up so
keep the dumbbell right in the center
and lift it and push it up if you want
to lift heavier good and the reason why
we want to do single sugar press if to
basically keep your muscles in balance
keep going
give me three more on the right side up
push it nice and high last to flip push
and bring it down and last one and push
it up good now let's change are still
maintaining shoulder width apart toes
points are forward okay
let's go down no break in between up
good you should feel one arm is stronger
than the other
nice look down and push it up good look
straight ahead
ah very good use the momentum slightly
but don't use the entire momentum and
push this way okay so always remember to
keep your body straight and your core
engaged last four more give me four more
up push last three more down push your
butt back okay remember to also pay
attention to your squat give me two more
up last one more and up very good put
the dumbbells down next workout is going
to be bent over row okay three-year-olds
with a deadlift if you want to you can't
keep to the same weights or challenge
yourself and lift heavy okay for this
one I'm going to go with eight kilos go
heavier isn't one to right
so stand shoulder width apart toes
pointed forward this will work on your
back muscles let's go down then squeeze
two three lift up squeeze your butt and
give me a nice a deadlift let's go for
five sets for this and up squeeze very
good third one deadlift squeeze good so
it's not about arching your lower back
but rather it is about squeezing and
engaging your glute muscles keep going
squeeze hold it squeeze and very good so
remember to engage and squeeze your back
muscles and good drop the weights we
want to keep pushing on all right next
is going to be a lunge and twist so I'm
going to do this without any weights
choose your weight okay so same thing a
basic lunge lunge forward twist to the
opposite side okay
lunch and twist so it's all about
engaging the core muscles let's go for
six kilos at least all right right then
shut over the pot take your wipe step
forward hold a dumbbell right in the
middle lunch
extend twist good bring it back lunch
extend twist that's one wrap let's go
for nine more - good
so by twisting you're engaging your core
and your obliques lunge forward work on
your legs and bring it back keep going
I know your shoulders are tired and
dropping don't drop it
forward and twist good bring your back
point both knees forward good back we're
halfway there give me five more twists
very good
so lunge first extend tight on the core
and bring it back good last four more I
can really zoom how to make muscles
working especially my shoulders right
now that's three more twist back don't
drop right now strong showed us okay
strong shoulders last two more let's go
twist back down twist last one more one
more all right let's go down twist you
should feel your heart rate raising and
forward right drop the weights
catch your breath we want to get down
onto the mat this is one of my favorite
exercises it's not easy but it's really
good so get down to the mat go for I
would say at least five to six kilos
it's going to be a plank road with a
push-up right so hold the dumbbells okay
get into a nice plank position spread
your both feet slightly give me an
unscrew shop and then row on the left up
row on the right to keep your body in a
straight line let's go - we want to go
for 10 okay keep your core tight it's a
really good total body workout three
down four squeeze your back squeeze your
back keep your body straight as much as
you can without arching or piking your
butt halfway there
five whoo give me five more I can see my
sweat dripping on the floor all right
keep going last four more nice solid
push up last three more down push up and
row last two more up and row last one
more up and row row breathe
okay breathe you have to my exercises
next workout tee raises okay it's going
to work on the front and also the side
of your shoulders go for lights awaits
all right you can choose three or two
kilos I'm good to go for three alright
so again stand shoulder width apart keep
your knees slightly bent bend slightly
from your waist and it's just a simple T
race
front and side good that's one two
squeeze hover right at the top three
very good for remember to breathe in
five six keep going
stay strong seven drop the weight
slightly if you need to but don't stop
now eight up last two not I'm just
raining right now last sorry 10 and up
well done right one final call workout
let's get back down onto the mat okay
all you'll need is one dumbbell okay so
grab six kilos if you want to lie on to
the mat let me just adjust my mic all I
want you to do is bring the dumbbell
back crunch in bring it back and give me
a nice lake race okay crunch in to rest
it lake race good three and lake race
good keep going last workout don't stop
now
four so remember to keep your legs as
straight as possible
five halfway there six remember to
breathe in and breathe out seven
last three more eight last two night
crunch through your upper and your lower
abs engaged and one more ten one last
leg raise and drop it rest it out and
just breathe and take a short break
shake your legs out and just stretch
your abs keep yourself hydrated because
we're not done yet we're going to go for
the second circuit so drink some water
and get ready by this time you know all
the workouts so I wanted you to give me
your best shot first workout squad with
single I'm sure the press choose to go
ahead there or drop your weight slightly
all right let's go I should have with a
pot first pointer forward give me a nice
deep squat okay just focus on one arm at
a time
lift up flip push it up very good down
push your box
sink your butt back okay you want to aim
for the dumbbell to kill as low as you
can if you can touch the floor
very good up nice give me six more flip
push it up okay tighten your core and
really straighten your body that's three
more last two more and change sides
immediately one more and let's go left
on now right on just keep it right
behind your lower back up flip and push
it up so which arm is stronger let me
know in the comments below I would say
my right arm is definitely stronger
hands for me
I have to work more on my left side to
balance it out
good keep going halfway there five more
push up straight last four more push it
up three more come on ladies come on
guys
keep going last two more push your butt
back squat as low as it can nice deep
squat and ah very good drop it down go
for heavier weights okay it's going to
be bent over row with a deadlift let's
go lift it up all right again
shut up with a pad nice soft and down
one squeeze two three and squeeze your
gluts
very good one two three power from your
heels squeeze the gluts
good hold it for at least one to two
counts squeeze and back down one two
three squeeze good this is the fifth set
two three squeeze let's go for two more
okay one two squeeze your mid back and
your glutes last one more whoo two three
and squeeze drop it
go for six kilos or five kilos because
we want to do lunch and twist right grab
your weight okay hold it right in the
center step back slightly and let's go
step forward reach and twist look the
opposite side good change leg and twist
very good
so it's all about keeping the core
balance to lunch
and twist look straight ahead okay your
shoulders should be in line directly in
front of your face not too low this is
wrong okay right let's go straight ahead
straight and twist
tighten those core work on your obliques
halfway there
give me five more breathe in and breathe
out good change lunch as slow as you can
feel your butt feel your hamstrings feel
your quads good keep going please in
pace your breathing and give me three
more whew
I am sweaty I studies dripping but we
don't stop now we stop when we're done
two more on each side down twist back
down twist this is not easy but it is a
really good total body strength training
back last one down and bring it back
Oh rest it a little bit shake it out
catch your breath we want to go down
onto the mat all right it's going to be
push-up with blank row okay so pick your
weights right are you ready remember to
always keep your entire body flat let's
go spread let's go
one nice solid push up row it up and row
good two
okay go deep three
stay with me guys I can feel your pain
or you should see your sweat dripping
five alright halfway there halfway there
let's keep going okay six seven stay
strong three more ah
take a shot breather let's go eight pull
it up pull it up last two don't stop
right now
breathe you have one more to go
ten well done see your sweat dripping
that's your hard work oh right let's get
back up and we want to do tea raises so
grab a lighter weight okay two or three
kilos each again Ben from your waist
slightly just very slightly keep your
knees soft and let's go T left and right
that's one okay
two left and right keep your back flat
three okay really focus on using your
arms and your shoulders four bring it
down slowly five control control halfway
there six control nice and control seven
and up eight up last two more keep it
strong nine and one more on both side
ten
ha shake and roll your shoulders right
one final core workout let's get back
down onto the mat ok you'll only need
one dumbbell alright it's going to be a
full body crunch with leg raise ok so
find your space and let's start crunch
rest it out let's go up and down good
crunch and to leg raise so you're really
working on your upper and lower abs and
really hitting the lower abs again four
push it up straight legs as much as you
can
five straight pointer toes six point
seven crunch last three more till you
get your break eight whoa breathe in and
breathe out last two more my legs are
you going
geli nine last one more ten oh just drop
it and rest it out take a deep long
breath in and slowly exhale once more
and exhale so that was two seconds if
you want to challenge yourself they
repeat this entire video once more and
complete four seconds we should aim for
at least two sessions of strength
training every week so I will recommend
two to three times of this video every
week so the common question is how heavy
should I lift well you should feel that
the weights are heavy enough and you
shouldn't struggle that slightly two
words at the end of the workout if you
find that you know what this is so easy
I am NOT struggling and
can even breathe very comfortably then
the weights are not heavy enough if
you're struggling and just struggling
throughout the entire exercise then the
weights are too heavy so you have to
find a way that's comfortable for you
and slowly progress alright guys so do
this workout share this workout video
with a friends challenge them to do it
with you like this video share this
video subscribe to my youtube channel
for a lot more workout videos healthy
recipes and also fitness tips don't
forget to hit and turn on the
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new video
all the best